during slavery post slavery
we want to make sure that we are not
doing anything that
would further create a barrier for
residents get ready gang because that is
going to be the left line and it's going
to be fun to watch
left eat the left and the the truth is
that the the the lack of understanding
of basic human behavior
by the media is pretty astonishing and
the willingness to believe the myth
that the only people who are not
vaccinating at this point are kooky fox
news watchers
that's also really weird we'll get to
that in just one second because there is
one it's the clip of the day okay it is
from a boston mayor
her name is kim janey okay she's the
black interim mayor
because she took the place of somebody
who joined the the
biden administration and this black
democratic mayor of boston
is saying things about vaccine mandates
that are significantly wilder than
anything republicans are saying but i
don't see joe biden attacking her
and there's a reason for that and it's
openly political
now you may notice that joe biden is
attacking ron desantis and greg abbott
and only
republican governors but what's weird is
that there are some democrats who are
pretty darned hesitant about things like
vaccine
mandates and vaccine passports one of
those people
is the current mayor of boston a woman
named kim jady
she of course took over for the former
mayor marty walsh who left to become
secretary of labor
under joe biden she is currently running
for a full term
and kim janey she got pretty damn spicy
about all of this she got very very
angry i think rightly so about some of
the vaccine mandate stuff but she's
using language
that is very i mean when i say spicy i'm
talking about like she took out like the
the full package of pepper and just
tossed it right on top of this here was
kim cheney the mayor
of boston a hardcore democrat there's a
long history in this country
of people needing to show their papers
during slavery
post-slavery as recent as
you know what the immigrant population
has to go through here
we heard trump with the birth
certificate nonsense
here we want to make sure that we are
not doing anything that
would further create a barrier for
residents okay and this is my favorite
she says
anything that would further create a
barrier for residents of boston or
disproportionately impact by poc
communities bipod communities
are people of color okay so she's now
comparing
vaccine passports to slavery and
that that's what she's doing and she's
also saying that it disproportionately
impacts black people
that's kind of an amazing statement i
don't see joe biden going after her
right where is joe biden why isn't he
saying you need to get out of the way
either do the right thing or get out of
the way weird he's not taking on the
democrat
who's saying this i noticed also he has
not
i've noticed very little from the biden
administration about how do you convince
the disproportionate number of black
people who have not gotten vaccinated to
get vaccinated
and it's good i've said before i think
it's going to be a lot of fun to watch
bill de blasio
and now they're talking about doing this
in l.a by the way watch bill de blasio
try to ban some 70 of black people from
being able to go to restaurants
because that's what the vaccine passport
does 70 of black people
in new york city are not vaccinated by
far
the highest rate of non-vaccination
among any demographic group
in new york city so what happens when
suddenly black people can't go to
restaurants and can't go to gyms and
can't go to indoor spaces can't go to a
yankee game
how does he think that's going to work
out for him the entire democratic party
has forwarded the lie that disparate
impact means
that discrimination has taken place so i
could easily say something like well you
know what
if it's a neutral rule then whether it
disproportionately impacts one group of
people or not really makes no difference
it's a neutral
rule right but democrats don't have that
foot to stand on they can't say that
if democrats were to acknowledge that
personal behavior is responsible for its
own consequences
then they couldn't make the case that
they are constantly making about
america's evil racism
which they are con which they're always
blaming for every disparity in american
life
from wealth and income inequality to
single motherhood
to drug abuse they're constantly
attempting
to chalk up every disparity in american
life to systemic racism so how do they
run away from this one exactly
that's what i find so amusing here when
kim janey says
that any policy that disproportionately
impacts bipod communities
must of course be discriminatory and
she's talking about vaccine passports
get ready gang because that is going to
be the left line and it's going to be
fun to watch the left eat the left
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content